back in my childhood and running into I
would say my early to mid 20s I was very
interested in war games of all sorts and
sort of spectrum that led into
role-playing games with all sorts of
cool stuff in the middle and I was
thinking about this in part because a
colleague of mine recently on Twitter I
guess he was digging around in his stuff
and he found some old Steve Jackson
games specifically those having to do
with the tank battles of the future
called ogre and jav and other things
like that and then the Illuminati games
that Steve Jackson had produced as well
and and people brought up another great
Steve Jackson game called car wars and
and it brought back all these in
interesting old memories of stuff that I
haven't really done anything with for
really decades and so you know the story
begins as far as I can remember I mean
you could say that it begins before it
really begins with those kinds of things
playing chess with my dad and with my
grandpa I mean chess is one of the
classic war games you know it's very
formalistic and stuff like that and I'm
not sure where I found this
advertisement
for a game that was from the Quinto game
company simply called battle
and
I remember reading about it and being
like that sounds pretty cool and I I
sent away you know six dollars to get it
in a game to my place and I I played it
with my dad a few times who I think he
wasn't that into those sorts of things
but he thought well this will be a great
thing for me and my my son to do
together and we would play these very
generic uh games uh you know hexagonal
things that had like you could do
Napoleonic Wars or Modern Warfare there
were a lot of different uh variations
and I was kind of learning about how War
Games worked war games not chess but war
games with the hexes and die cut
counters and that sort of thing and
yaquinto was a sort of new entry to the
gay to the game World there was also
Avalon Hill which had put out a number
of games by that time and then this drew
me into an entire an entire world you
could say right
um and so I started getting interested
in more and more complex War Games The
Challenge was always to find people who
would play them with you because I
didn't live in a city I lived out in the
countryside in near the the village of
Wales and there there weren't a lot of
other kids who were particularly
interested in doing that kind of stuff
we played board games like sorry and
Parcheesi and you know we had that
vibrating thing with the football
players one of my when I say we I mean
one of my friends did where the football
players would bump into each other you'd
have plays and stuff like that and then
of course they were handheld you know
sports games that were becoming popular
as well with the really
um nowadays you know terrible LED lights
and very rudimentary programming but I
was interested in these imaginary games
and
again I I'm not sure what magazines I
was getting that had stuff like this in
it it might have been like in boy's life
or something uh like that way back then
but I you know that that first war game
kind of got me hooked and then
you know I I wanted to play more and
more of these things
um
and then a little bit later and it would
have been I think the Christmas of
1980.
yeah or a 1981. my parents
I guess it was in part because I was
into fantasy literature uh and sci-fi
stuff they got me Dungeons and Dragons
the beginners set and I I remember
actually like being fascinated with that
and bringing it along to Christmas mass
and like reading through the rule book
while I'm supposed to be paying
attention to what's going on in church
and you know my parents were happy
because I was being quiet
and it was really cool and I started you
know thinking this is really interesting
stuff and you know I want to say it
probably was 1980
um
yeah because I would have I would have
been in uh sixth grade because there
were some other kids that I met who were
into that sort of stuff my friend Steve
my friend John who went to my school my
friend Keith who had gone to elementary
school with and you know we would try to
to do this role playing stuff and then I
I realized that there were other you
know extensions to this so the Dungeons
and Dragons you know you had the
beginners thing you had the advance and
as it turned out my Uncle John had some
of the even earlier Dungeons and Dragons
stuff because his brother-in-law Bill
these are down in Chicago was into this
sort of thing so I had I had him to chat
with
um and you know they they actually gave
me some of their old rule books and the
funny thing was I'm trying to make sense
of all of this and wrap my head around
it and the stuff doesn't actually map on
to each other other quite so coherently
anyway long story short I get you know
into war games a bit more my dad
unfortunately passes away in August of
1982. otherwise I think he would have
been quite interested in in you know
these things with me as well and
in a way
um
doing this kind of stuff
the fantasy you know role-playing and
the war gaming and the other things that
I was getting into was uh an escape from
the not really dealing with grief very
well and all that kind of stuff and then
you know I'd find people who are into
gaming in general and so it went on a
couple different directions like for
example my friend John he had a younger
brother Mark and they were into the
Steve Jackson game stuff with car wars
and uh ogre to a certain degree which
was this you know futuristic tank games
Car Wars is sort of like a Mad Max you
know you put guns on your cars and you
know everybody's driving between cities
and it's kind of post-apocalyptic and we
had lots and lots of fun and all of
these things were just kind of like
being churned out and I remember being
allowed to play some DND with with some
of my friends in Middle School like
during break times and of course we get
made fun of you know oh you bunch of
nerds and stuff like that but we're
we're really into it we could never get
things working all the way through like
we never really made it through an
entire module so there was the
role-playing aspect and then that led me
into other role-playing games along with
other people who I knew so you know I
bought Gamma World which was another TSR
TSR did the uh The Dungeons and Dragons
and Gamma World was somewhat compatible
with it that was a post-apocalyptic
post-nuclear apocalypse game as well and
um what else did I I got my hands on
paranoia at one time never actually got
to play it unfortunately
um and on the other hand
I was doing the other you know tabletop
war games we had a neighbor who kind of
wanted to be my surrogate dad uh Bill
Maris and and he would he had a whole
bunch of these games and he would lend
them to me some of which I kept forever
um and uh you know sometimes I'd lose
some of the counters and stuff too and
and sometimes he and I would play these
games together and that was a lot of fun
stay up late you know match wits in
Blitzkrieg or this there was a Frederick
the great the Seven Years War there was
a game called War and Peace that he lent
me that was the entire Napoleonic Wars
that I played on a massive coffee table
um just as a side note sometimes I'd get
these things set up and then my dog
would come in the room and she had that
she was a black lab German Shepherd mix
and so she had a big long bushy tail and
she'd walk by and she'd like you know
her Tails sweep all these things off
there was a World War II game called
Third Reich that I would play as well
and oftentimes I played these games
where I would take each side and I would
play against myself and so you know this
sort of thing continued on
um
you know there's Bill Maris there was uh
playing these games with the uh the two
brothers and sometimes with with some
other friends and then I had a friend
from middle school who I started hanging
out with in freshman and sophomore year
and he and I went to Gen Con together
and uh Gen Con if you don't know is like
the the big Gamers Mecca and it used to
be here in Milwaukee in Mecca and so my
mom drove us out and he and I like went
in has these on a whole bunch of
miniature figurines which then we had to
paint and stuff like that and we got
some rules for for you know War gaming
and we would we would play in his his
place and we would have these massive
battles we also got into the Avalon Hill
um it wasn't squad leader which I had
later it was the the Panzer things which
had to do with tank battles and you know
you could make these massive maps and
have these giant battle between the the
German and the Russian forces or German
and British forces or you could actually
make the Brits fight the Russians if you
wanted to right so I was I was getting
into this pretty heavy and doing
different things with different people
and then you know what ended up
happening I I would say is I you know I
ended up like not wanting to go over to
the two brothers place because their
parents are really and now I recognize
that they were hoarders and I kind of
didn't like the scene and so I wasn't
doing I was doing less and less with
them me and one of the other guys Steve
we we started doing stuff that had more
to do with like playing chess and
watching movies and making popcorn and
drinking you know uh soda and listening
to music together and stuff like that
George and I kind of split ways as well
I think in part because I was really a
mess in high school and he was kind of
going places you know
um and so we we he you know he started
getting into rock climbing and I wasn't
into that but I did have other friends
um that I would play like axis and
allies with and uh that was quite a bit
of fun uh with Marshall and some of the
you know Ed and some of these these
other people
and um
you know I continued playing some of the
other games and then you know I finished
high school and went off and was in the
Army and interestingly while I was in
the Army I actually played a lot of D
and D because weirdly enough in you know
uh the unit that I was in there were a
lot of guys who were into that and it
was it was okay there were a lot of
people who were what we call rules
lawyers where they're always trying to
like you know argue about stuff or they
were trying to maximize their stats or
their their playing their I think there
were a lot of guys who were like
indulging their feminine side because
they'd roll themselves up some you know
female uh half elf and then you know
basically she would sleep with the other
non-player characters and stuff like
that
um but you know it was It was kind of
fun and then I I get out of the army and
I I knew this guy Bill who lived in
Wauwatosa which is you know close that's
in the Milwaukee area and he and his his
friends all these 20-somethings they
were into role-playing games as well uh
in particular Twilight 2000 which then
um you know somebody who'd been in the
military
uh I I was sort of a natural for that so
they he would come out and pick me up
and Waukesha which we were living in by
then we'd move from Wales to Waukesha
and I'd come out and hang out with him
and his brother and all these other
friends and we'd play Twilight 2000 and
occasionally other games as well so you
know
there were a lot of uh people to do
interesting things but then I went up to
college and there were some people who
were into gaming up there as well and we
we played Twilight 2000 we actually
adapted it to some sort of zombie
scenario and I made up a whole bunch of
stuff I was gm'ing by then
um and and there were some other people
who were into doing the the board games
as well I I got to play squad leader
with with a few people and
um you know that continued on it was
always something that was kind of a fun
side thing to do and and I'll say I
never really got to develop really not
to got to engage in these things to
their full potential you know like
campaigns would start and then they
would end halfway through the campaign
because people would get too busy or
somebody would get a girlfriend or I
would get a girlfriend then you know or
I would I would get more into playing
cards in the party room or something
like that I did a lot of partying back
in in college I also played soccer for
for a while to help train people on the
soccer team so I was a pretty busy guy
and
um but it was it was a fun part of my
existence that never really went that
far as as perhaps I would have liked I
don't know if I'll ever get back into
the hobby again you know Dungeons and
Dragons is now on like 5th Edition I
started out with first edition so I have
no clue what's going on with that and
there's probably other interesting
role-playing games that I could get
involved in or tabletop things I mean
now it's basically
um Katan with my wife and kids
occasionally or you know we have some
plans to do it with other couples but
it's never actually panned out and
that's fun too you know
um I there's maybe part of your brain
that likes all of this you know board
gaming role playing all the things in
between I used to spend hours and hours
you know painting these miniature
figures that we would use for stuff and
I think about all the the many I mean if
you added them up they're probably
months or years that I spent on all of
this stuff and you can say well what a
waste you know you're a philosopher now
you could have been using that time to
read books or something
but I don't think it was a waste I think
it was an important part of my childhood
and Adolescence
and early adulthood and I don't know if
I'll ever get really back into it again
I don't know if I have the time to but
it was a lot of fun and so I think
that's pretty cool so maybe that's where
I'll well there's one other thing I'll
tell you about before I end the story so
there's there's a book out there that's
hard to get your hands on although there
is a PDF floating around on the internet
and it's called Fantasy war gaming and
you got to remember that in the 1980s
all these different companies all these
different people were putting out game
systems some of which uh were quite
successful think about Dungeons and
Dragons some of which were pretty cool
but never lived up to their full
potential and didn't get the traction
that they wanted some of which tried to
do a little bit of everything you think
about gurps you know the generic
Universal role-playing game which I also
did with Bill and his brother and some
of these other people now that I recall
and this Fantasy war gaming was was an
attempt to try to make it very
historical it was a it was in one book
never got to play it with anybody but
the the rule system to me looked pretty
cool and I would spend hours reading
through this book I even remember like
taking it on Spring Break
um
it got very little love from other
Gamers as a matter of fact if you go
online and look it up people say it's
one of the worst systems ever developed
you know but I actually thought it was
pretty cool and I think that you know
there's probably a lot of other things
out there like that where
um you know some people will criticize
it but others will say ah there's
there's something kind of kind of neat
here
um and so
you know I haven't thought about these
things for quite a long time but I was
spurred to Again by my colleague posting
uh the Steve Jackson games that I got to
play to some degree but not as much as I
would have liked and uh I think it's
kind of cool that that nowadays if
you're into that sort of stuff
um you know it's it's become part of Pop
Culture think about stranger things
right or other uh things where the Nerds
are no longer you know uh treated so
quite so badly by the the cool kids and
and stuff like that so that's uh kind of
a Meandering story about uh War Games
role-playing games miniature figures all
of that sort of business I'm not quite
sure what uh to what rubric to associate
all this under but there's my story for
you